soweit der präsident der ukraine sie
lenski vor dem norwegischen parlament
ich kann jetzt über das sprechen was uns
natürlich sehr interessiert nämlich die
frage wie ist die taktik der russen
einzuschätzen ich spreche mit dem
militär historiker professor sönke
neitzel den ich sehr herzlich begrüßen
wie muss man diesen rückzug den
angekündigten rückzug der nicht so ganz
klar ist bei dem was wir aus kiew gehört
haben bruchteil
naja wir uns allen wächst natürlich die
hoffnung auf ein ende dieses krieges
wächst die hoffnung auf eine
diplomatische lösung und das erinnert
mich ein bisschen an den ausbruch des
krieges wo ja gut hin auch schon mal
truppen abgezogen hat oder gesagt der
elektro abziehen und schon die
nachrichtensprecher weiß noch aufsteigen
müssen also ich würde sagen nach dem 24
februar gibt es keine gewissheiten mehr
wir können überhaupt nicht sagen wie das
ausgeht militärisch gesehen glaube ich
nach wie vor nicht daran dass putin am
ende seiner möglichkeiten ist ich glaube
dass er diese truppen abzieht aus kiew
sie in den don was verlegt oder anderen
ort ziehen um militärisch die
verhandlungssituation russlands zu
verbessern und ich würde mir natürlich
wünschen dass der krieg zu ende ist oder
sehr bald zu ende ist aber ich würde
leider da ein fragezeichen machen wollen
sie dass wir an seinen film wenn das
taktik ist dann muss man sich ja auch
fragen was ist denn eigentlich die
taktische taktik der russischen armee
gewesen die ja offenbar wenn sie sich
jetzt von kiew zurückzieht wie sie sagen
zwar nicht gf aufgibt aber zeigt dass
sie dann doch das nicht als schwerpunkt
nehmen kann ihrer militärischen optionen
war das einfach nicht funktioniert
ja wir sehen also ganz offensichtlich
dass der zugriff auf kiew licht
funktioniert hat und wir müssen zwei
phasen unterscheiden die erste phase mit
dem stellen und auch druck schlag die
luftlande cluster auf den flug dürfen
und dann eine zweite phase wir haben ja
sehr schwere kämpfe um dich herum gehabt
wirklich sehr schwere kämpfe im hohen
einsatz von artillerie und auch mal
diesen dieser hohen feuerkraft haben uns
die russen nicht geschafft die
ukrainische verteidigung ein zu stoßen
und ich glaube dass die russischen
streitkräfte sich jetzt konzentrieren
müssen oder das wollen wir können
natürlich nur mutmaßen wir alle haben da
keinen einblick aber an die russen sind
zu diesem zeitpunkt vor einer gewaltigen
länge der front verteilt von kiew am
lauten bis märz sollen im süden und das
ist sicher sinnvoll aus militärischer
sicht jetzt schwerpunkte zu bilden um
zumindest die gemälde der beiden
volksrepublik in freizukämpfen aus
russischer sicht und wer weiß was sie
noch vor haben viele
kommentatoren sprechen ja auch davon was
die russen versuchen könnten östlich von
charkow nach süden vorzustoßen um die
ukrainischen streitkräfte im damals
einzukesseln also wir alle wissen das
nicht können die karten nur
interpretieren aber eine verlagerung von
schwerpunkten eine umorganisation haben
wir ihn kriegen immer wieder gesehen
insofern ist das dieses außergewöhnlich
man hat ja auch so ein bisschen den
eindruck es wird immer mal wieder
taktiert und ausprobiert wie reagiert
der westen auch der westen probiert
natürlich das ein oder andere aus um
auch im zweifel die russische armee ein
bisschen vom weg abzubringen wie ist
denn die perspektive wir haben gehört
taktische atomwaffen könnten eingesetzt
werden da wurde auch mit gedroht wir
haben von chemiewaffen gehört was ist
denn zu erwarten kann man so etwas
einschätzen
ja ich komme wieder auf mein punkt
zurück seit dem 24 februar können wir
uns überhaupt nicht sicher sein meines
erachtens und weil wir ja ein gut wie
nicht in den kopf schauen und seine
logik nicht so wirklich verstehen und
ich würde nach wie vor alles für
möglichkeiten vielleicht nicht für sehr
wahrscheinlich immer alles für möglich
und die große frage vor der wir stehen
auch die analysten der nato und der
küste soweit ich das beurteilen kann ist
wie sieht es eigentlich in den
russischen streitkräften wirklich aus
wie weit ist die kampfkraft wirklich
geschwächt und wie sieht s bei der
ukrainischen ami aus von der wir nach
wie vor kaum etwas wissen genauere
angaben
und nur wenn wir das genau wissen
müssten wäre es möglich wir haben
stärkere angaben darüber zu machen ob
putin wirklich am ende seiner
militärischen möglichkeiten ich kann mir
das zu diesem zeitpunkt noch nicht
vorstellen die russen haben noch ich
weiß nicht 2000 panzer oder so sie haben
noch viele flugzeuge wir sie nicht
eingesetzt haben und die frage ist ja ab
welchem punkt ist putin bereits auf die
militärische karte zu verzichten und
stärker auf die diplomatie zu setzen und
ich würde es ähnlich alkohol ist wie sie
eben in der moderation gesagt haben was
sehen das sind immer wieder auch
taktische versuche das ist mal wieder
ein zocker spiel wenn wir uns also jetzt
zurückziehen wir verhandeln ist dann der
westen vielleicht bereit kann man den
westen spalten lockern sie vielleicht
die diese aktion das geht jetzt ja auch
um die frage ob die gaslieferung mit
rubel bezahlt werden also das ist ein
spiel auf und es ist sicherlich ein
spiel um die hoffnung des westens nach
frieden und wir glauben wir müssen uns
alle auf eine längere konfrontation
einstellen wir müssen vor allen dingen
fest bleiben und den staat bleiben die
ukraine weiter militärisch unterstützen
das ist putin nicht gelingt militärisch
sein ein sieg davonzutragen darum dass
er letztlich verhandeln muss aber es ist
eben auch die gefahr dabei das können
wir einfach nicht gut sein dass da in
die ecke gedrängt wird und zu radikalen
maßnahmen greift also mit dieser neuen
möglichkeit müssen wir einfach rechten
und zeitenwende heißt eben leider auch
mit dieser dimensionen leben zusammen
professor simulation ganz herzlichen
dank an sie